in the ancient books it's written that a
warrior will draw a burning sword from
the fire and that sword shall be
Lightbringer
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight Theory video in today's video I
want to update a theory I made about six
months ago when I was making my endgame
predictions for each character I made
one about Melisandre and I talked about
what I think her ultimate purpose is the
first video I made on this topic was
pretty good in my opinion but I have
read the books again and I believe I
found even more evidence that proves
this theory to be true there are a few
different quotes that I think point
directly to Melisandre being nice and
ISA and I know this prophecy is
constantly mentioned to these days but
almost everyone references Daenerys when
they talk about Nissa Nissa but at the
end of the day I think that's completely
wrong now I do have to say the theory I
want to show you today mostly relates to
the books because that's where I found
most of these clues also I know one of
the recent plot Leakes said Melisandre
was nice Aneesa but I actually made the
theory videos 6 months before that leak
came out and now I want to show you why
I believe Melisandre will have to give
the ultimate sacrifice because in order
to create this ultimate weapon
Melisandre will need to die first let me
set the stage for why I think a special
weapon like light bringer will be needed
I think there is a very good chance that
Jon and Daenerys cannot win this war
with what they have the night king has a
dragon he has Giants and according to
Daenerys the night king has a hundred
thousand soldiers in his army that are
built to fight in the snow plus we know
the night king can add more soldiers to
his army at pretty much any time I
believe that in order for Jon and
Daenerys to win this war they will need
some kind of an x-factor some kind of an
outside force that no one would see
coming which leads me to Melisandre as
we all know this is the Song of Ice and
Fire and that title describes more than
just one thing it has been a theme
throughout this entire series and it
will play its biggest part in the end
the night King has a direct connection
to ice he can actually manipulate the
ice and a powerful weapons that can take
down a dragon with a single strike Jon
and Daenerys will need a weapon that
represents the fire side of things that
the knight King cannot stop some of you
may say they already have
weapon because they have fire-breathing
dragons but we already know the night
king can defeat dragons he killed one
dragon very easily in my opinion the
Dragons will not be the ultimate weapons
this will come down to one verse one
combat then I king will have his magical
ice weapon and John will need a magical
fire weapon this is foreshadowed in the
books and it was also shown in the show
now in order for this weapon to be made
we have to look at the prophecy this
sword needs to be plunged into a heart
that turns the fire in forges the blade
and Melisandre has that direct
connection to the fire she can see
things in the flames and she can even
manipulate the flames she might be doing
that with her powders and potions but
she does have power inside of her
Melisandre has a fire burning inside of
her and this has been referenced two
more times than I can count
Melisandre also knows she will be needed
to defeat the knight King this was the
very last thing she said to Jon Snow
I've been ready to die for many years if
the Lord was done with me so be it but
he's not you've seen the night King Jon
Snow
you know the Great War still to come you
know the army of the Dead will be upon
us soon and you know I can help you win
them whoa Jon is going to need
Melisandre to stop the night King but
Melisandre will have to die in order for
this to be done let me read the prophecy
how this is worded is very important
because some of this wording is used
again and other quotes about Melisandre
and Jon this prophecy was first laid out
in a dvash captor Salladhor santel x'
him the story about azor Ahai and niece
and ISA and this is what he says do you
know the tale of the forging of light
bringer I shall tell it to you it was a
time when darkness lay heavy on the
world to oppose it the hero must have a
hero's blade like none that had ever
been and so for thirty days and 30
nights azor Ahai labored sleepless in
the temple forging a blade in the sacred
fires heat and hammer and fold heat and
hammer and fold oh yes until the sword
was done
yet when he plunged it into water to
temper the steel it burst asunder the
second time it took him 50 days and 50
nights and this sword seemed even finer
than the first
Ozora high captured a lion to temper the
blade by plunging it through the beasts
red heart but once more the steel
shattered and split great was his woe
and great was his sorrow then for he
knew what he must do a hundred days and
a hundred nights he labored on the third
blade and as it glowed white-hot in the
sacred fires he summoned his wife Nissa
Nissa he said to her for that was her
name bear your breast and know that I
love you best of all that is in this
world she did this thing why I cannot
say an azure 'hi thrust the smoking
sword through her living heart it is
said that her cry of anguish and ecstasy
left a crack across the face of the moon
but her blood in her soul and her
strength and her courage all went into
the steel all right now there is a lot
to take in here but some of this wording
is the key to Melisandre being nice and
Nisa I know some of you might get hung
up on the part about Nissa Nissa needing
to be as or ahyes wife but I will
explain why that's not exactly true and
some of you probably think the sword
needs to be forged three times for this
to work too but I don't think that's
necessarily true either that needed to
be done the first time but it won't need
to be done with azor Ahai reborn and I
will explain that later as well now
let's think about Melisandre role in the
story so far if you've read the books
then you know all Melisandre talks about
is azor Ahai and how he will be the one
to defeat the darkness her life's work
has been to find azor Ahai and prepare
him for when the time comes
Melisandre believes she found a surah
high in Stannis Baratheon she believes
he is the one and she is constantly
making sacrifices to help Stannis's
cause Melisandre has no problem with
burning people alive at the stake in
fact Melisandre believes death by fire
is the purest death the only problem is
Melisandre is focusing on the wrong man
and you could even say she is making
unnecessary sacrifices I believe what
Melisandre has been doing will be turned
on its head and Melisandre will need to
make one
last sacrifice but this time she wife to
give herself to the fire the fire that's
inside of her she has already found the
true azor Ahai but if she actually wants
to help him defeat the night king she
will have to give herself in order for
this magical sword to be created
Melisandre has said there will come a
day after a long summer when the stars
bleed and the cold breath of darkness
falls heavy on the world in this dread
hour a warrior shall draw from the fire
a burning sword and that sword shall be
Lightbringer the red sword of Heroes and
he who clasps it shall be Azure 'hi come
again in the darkness shall flee before
him azor Ahai beloved / allure the
warrior of light the son of fire now
think about what Melisandre said azor
Ahai beloved / allure the warrior of
light the son of fire that sounds a lot
like John John was brought back to life
by rule or you could say he was reborn
making him the son of fire John is
actually the son of ice and fire but
George only wrote fire right here
because he only gives us bits and pieces
at a time to not make it too obvious
also when Melisandre looks into the
flames she praised her Lord to give her
just a glimpse of as aura highs face but
whenever he shows her all she can see is
snow well or doesn't show her any sign
that points to Stannis Baratheon because
he's not the one he's a pretender well
or only shows Melisandre the snow which
obviously represents John another
interesting thing that points to John
being a Zora hi is a dream he has in the
most recent book in a dance with dragons
John has a dream that he's standing on
top of the wall John is armored in black
ice but his blade burned red in his fist
both of these Clues are in the last book
George is slowly starting to reveal who
this legendary figure will be but now
let me show you some other reasons why I
believe John will need Melisandre to
forge this sword in her burning heart
one of the most obvious clues is the
symbol that represents Melisandre it's
something we have all seen a thousand
times but we never put two and two
together
Melisandre carries a banner that has a
burning heart this is exactly what will
happen in milla soldier's heart
once John plunges his sword into our
chest there is also another quote and
wanted Davos his chapters that talks
about Melisandre and it's worded exactly
like the Nissa Nissa prophecy I'm sure
most of you remember the battle in
Blackwater Bay do you remember how Davos
his son was killed by the Wildfire well
in the books Davos actually loses
multiple sons during this battle on the
bay and he's obviously very emotional
and angry about this and he wants to
kill Melisandre because of this among
many other reasons after Davos survives
the battle he lands on that rock and he
eventually gets rescued just like in the
show but as he is on his way back to
Dragonstone he starts thinking to
himself about how he wants to kill
Melisandre as soon as he gets there and
this is what he says I will cut the
living heart from her breast and see how
it burns that's fascinating because it's
very specific and it's foreshadowing how
Melisandre will actually die but the
wording is nearly identical to how nice
Aneesa died Davo said he wants to cut
into her bare breasts and into her
living heart to see how it burns there
is another reference to Melisandre
having a burning heart but it also says
living heart just like the prophecy
mentions a living heart and of course it
burns after it's cut in two which will
look exactly like Melisandre has banners
now I want to read another quote and I
just recently came across this one as I
was reading the books again when I saw
this quote it pretty much jumped off the
page and slapped me right in the face
because I think these small details are
actually another direct link to
Melisandre being niece Aneesa when Jon
and Melisandre wrote in the cage
together to the top of the wall he
notices some very interesting things
about Melisandre in the close confines
of the iron cage he was acutely aware of
the red woman's presence she even smells
red the scent reminded him of my
conserve the way iron smelled when red
hot the scent was smoked in blood kissed
by fire let me stop right there first
because that is an absolute bombshell
Jon can smell Melisandre and it reminds
him of Mike insane way iron smells when
red hot the scent was smoked in blood
that's fascinating because Melisandre
basically smells
exactly like Nissa Nissa what smell
after the sword was forged in her heart
the sword smoked and burned as her blood
poured over it and that's exactly what
Melisandre smells like smoke and blood
mic ins Forge Melisandre smells like a
freshly forged sword because this is
foreshadowing exactly what's going to
happen to her
why else is her body giving off that
scent other than a calling to John about
what needs to be done but this isn't all
that said in the cage as they rise to
the top of the wall John notices that
Melisandre is never cold when it's
freezing at the wall even when you wear
heavy furs John even asks her this you
are not cold my lady
all Melisandre does is laugh and she
says never the Ruby at her throat seems
to pulse in time with the beating of her
heart she says the Lord's fire lives
within me Jon Snow feel then she puts
Jon's hand to her cheek and he held it
there so he could feel how warm she was
now do not forget that detail because
that's very important also Melisandre is
always warm she has a fire burning
inside of her let me show you something
else now when maester aemon leaves the
wall to go to the Citadel with Sam he
leaves one very important thing behind
for Jon to read he even marks the page
for Jon because he knows Jon must see
this and can you guess what it's about
it's about azor Ahai in Nissa Nissa but
what Jon actually says when he reads it
is fascinating as well this is what John
says I looked at the book maester aemon
left me the Jade compendium the pages
that told of azor Ahai Lightbringer was
his sword tempered with his wife's blood
if votar can be believed thereafter
Lightbringer was never cold to the touch
but warm as Nissa Nissa had been warm do
you see the connection there
Nissa Nissa was always warm just like
Melisandre is always warm and nice
aneesa's life force forged into the
blade which is why the blade is always
warm and basically glowing red Nissa
Nissa had a fire inside of her just like
Melisandre but there is something else
Jon said right there that I have to
point out remember how I said Nissa
Nissa doesn't have to be the person's
wife well look at what John said the
pages that told of azor Ahai
Lightbringer was his sword tempered with
his wife's blood
if votar can be believed the way that
last sentence is worded is very
important because the detail about Nissa
Nissa being a Zora his wife needs to be
put into question because botar was the
man who documented this prophecy and I
think that is George telling us that the
last detail about it being his wife's
blood may or may not be true
Nissa Nissa was not actually his wife
which means Melisandre does not need to
be John's wife to fit the prophecy
notice how John doesn't mention the
sword being forged three times either
that's because John won't have to do
that he will only need to forge it once
he just needs to realize what he needs
to do which is one of the reasons why
maester aemon left him this book in the
first place John needed to know that
Stannis was not azor Ahai because
maester aemon noticed Stannis's sword
was cold to the touch and the real light
bringer should be warm if it was legit
but George doesn't just do things in his
story for one reason and one reason only
that book will make John realize Stannis
is Ana's aura hi and John will realize
that his dream about him armored and
black ice and holding a red burning
sword in his hand relates to him being a
Zora hi and he will need to plunge his
sword into the person that has been
sacrificing everyone for the wrong
reasons
if Melisandre truly wants to help Ozora
hi then she will give herself to the
fire she will give herself what she
believes to be the purest death she has
the fire burning inside of her and she
needs to transfer that energy into
John's sword
just like Nissa Nissa did thousands of
years ago when she looks into the flames
for a glimpse of azor Ahai all she sees
is snow it doesn't get any more clear
than that there is another thing I want
to show you before I end the video there
was actually a scene from the show where
Melisandre told John they could make
light together and light is obviously
short for light bringer I can't show you
the full scene because Melisandre is
partially nude but I will play all the
audio listen very carefully to her words
do you feel my heart beating
this power in you you resist it and
that's your mistake embraces in our
joining this power
power to make life power to make light
John puts his hand on Melisandre as bare
breasts and she asks him if he can feel
her heart sounds like another hint to
the Nissa Nissa prophecy because Nissa
Nissa bared her breast then the sword
went into her heart and created light
bringer as John feels Melisandre's
breast in her heart beating Melisandre
says John has power in him that he needs
to embrace together they can make life
together they can make light Melisandre
will bear her breast one last time but
John's sword will be the thing that
feels her heartbeat and together they
will make light bringer Thoris of Maher
once said great power requires great
sacrifice
Melisandre left Westeros but she knows
she must come back to perform one final
sacrifice she has given so many people
to the fire but now it's only fitting
that she gives herself in order to end
this darkness that has come to lay over
the world it's no accident that they
showed Gilly reading a page straight out
of the world of Ice and Fire
about Ozora high this will all come into
play in the end and this is how I think
it goes down I feel like the evidence is
overwhelmingly points to Melisandre
being nice Aneesa but this is just my
opinion let me know how you feel about
this one that I provide enough clues or
are you still on the fence put all your
thoughts and questions down below in the
comment section I know this was a long
one but I really appreciate those of you
who made it until the end and I also
have to give a special shout-out to
everyone on patreon supporting the
channel thank you all so much I hope you
have a great day and I will see you in
the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you